die köpfe hinter den sogenannten
alternativen medien heiko schrank
bolivar janyk can jepsen ihre
verbreitungsplattform ist das netz die
videos werden massenhaft geklickt der
inhalt polarisiert und provoziert
[Musik]
denn jetzt ins video games körper
deutschland wurde über drei millionen
mal aufgerufen
im video behauptet jetzt bill gates
finanziere die
weltgesundheitsorganisation zu 80
prozent laut gates stiftung sind es aber
lediglich zehn prozent jepsen will vor
allem eins die massen mobilisieren
liegt hier mit riesenschritten in eine
digitale diktatur und deswegen möchte
ich an dieser stelle die deutsche
bevölkerung
explizit dazu aufrufen sich dem
entgegenzustellen die axt in monza die
angst von getränke hat von außen
[Musik]
dabei ist es ihm offenbar egal wie sich
ihm anschließt
im weg an die front wir befinden uns an
gebeten sind auf dem weg an die front
spielt es keine rolle ob du auf der
rechten oder linken seite marschiert um
zu verstehen was
verschwörungstheoretiker
denken und erreichen wollen stellen wir
bereits vor monaten die ersten
interview-anfragen
wie bekommen viele absagen
[Musik]
einer der derzeit keine kamera scheut
ist attila hildmann bekannt geworden als
vorzeige veganer mischt er seit monaten
die verschwörer szene auf seinen
sozialen netzwerken verbreitet er corona
mythen zeigt sich mitunter als
bewaffneter widerstandskämpfer
wir filmen ihnen ende mai in berlin
während einer seiner wöchentlichen
kundgebungen vor dem reichstag
wir haben verschiedene player dieses
spiel skyrama für politik und jetzt
kommt dieser technische
regel bei den corona gewinnen und das
ist bereits mit seiner foundation
der feind ist benannt ein wichtiges
instrument von verschwörungstheoretikern
gut gegen böse wir gegen die überall in
deutschland wird mit der angst gespielt
mit der angst vor einem angeblich bösen
staat der dem volk die rechte nehmen
möchte
ist es nicht ein anschnitt in eure
körperliche unversehrtheit dass der
staat sich anmaßt das habe ich eine
spritze verpassen kann
ich höre nichts
viele menschen eint das misstrauen gegen
die korona maßnahmen wo hört der
kritische zweifel auf wo fängt die
verschwörungstheorie an
am rande bekommen wir zufällig diese
diskussion geht
inzwischen
das ist ja das liegt bei die maßnahmen
gemacht wurden
sag mir doch mal woher hast du denn
deine woche her hast du denn deine
informationen du hast du denn
informationen
ich habe mir den kennen ich habe mir den
canon epson angehört aber ich will mir
auf den rost wann hast du denn drauf der
virologe drosten microsoft gründer gates
minister sparen die menschen hier haben
ihre feindbilder auf die sie ihre wut
und enttäuschung projizieren
[Musik]
viele demonstranten sind zum ersten mal
auf einer kundgebung kommen aus dem
bürgerlichen milieu selten hatten wir es
so schwer mit ihnen ins gespräch zu
kommen
gerade ihre sender diffamieren doch alle
kritiker und stellt alle in die rechte
ecke suchen sie sich ihre wahrheit sagen
wir richten uns objekte die frage kann
ich ihnen jetzt ganz präzise beantworten
sorry wenn ich früher nicht gemacht habt
ja ich schaue mir die sogenannten
alternativen medien an so genanntes
jetzt nicht als wäre als negativer
gemeint und ich finde da bin ich besser
informiert
zum beispiel oder mmnews
rubicon
weiß ich jetzt nicht als eine ganze
menge die man findet dann braucht man
gar nicht
so weit es geht
wir treffen christian er fühlt sich in
seinen grundrechten eingeschränkt das
vertrauen in die politik hatte aber
schon lange verloren
nichts in der politik geschieht ohne
oder auszufallen ja und das ist halt
immer so gewesen und von daher denke ich
ja da kann man spekulieren
mit dieser befürchtung ist christian
nicht allein wie die demonstrationen der
vergangenen wochen gezeigt haben viele
haben sich vom staat abgewandt und
fühlen sich stigmatisiert
doch die esoterik die rechtsradikalen
üblichen kampfbegriffe die dafür
geschaffen worden um leute die anders
denken beziehungsweise jetzt schon
einige mainstream entsprechen so zu
sagen ja ruhig zu stellen
beziehungsweise lächerlich zu machen
dass sich extremistische gruppen
durchaus unter die demonstranten mischen
wird sich später noch zeigen
die wut auf der straße hat ihren
ursprung im netz wie schnell das
internet zum brandbeschleuniger von
vermeintlichen verschwörungs ideologien
werden kann die offenbar auch immer mehr
die mitte der gesellschaft erreichen
wollen wir an der tu münchen
herausfinden über
mehrere wochen haben die beiden
wissenschaftler für big data youtube
videos zu corona analysiert warum fängt
jemand an zu suchen bei youtube der hat
eine idee zu corona der will wissen was
passiert da eigentlich da geht es um die
impfpflicht da geht es um kritik an der
regierung um vorgehen das heißt da wird
er dann auch immer in frage gestellt
sind ist dass alles korrekt gibt es das
überhaupt
etwa die hälfte der rund 300
analysierten videos haben einen
kritischen und fragwürdigen inhalt wenn
man sich dann das netzwerk dieser
kritischen inhalte anschaut dann merkt
man dass hier ungefähr jedes fünfte
diese videos klar ein verschwörungs -
der weg zum nächsten verschwörungs
mythos der gar nichts mehr mit corona zu
tun hat sei dann nicht mehr weit
was hier passiert ist dass wir was er
von einem verschwörungs meter zum
nächsten gehen das heißt dass wir quasi
aus der krone blase der kritischen
berichterstattung dann quasi in die
nächste in die die verschwörungs mythen
glasl übergeführt werden aber wäre
youtube nicht in der pflicht diese
videos auch als verschwörungs mythen zu
markieren youtube ist ganz gut im
relativ wenig einzugreifen und dennoch
den größten halbwegs in den griff zu
bekommen aber wir sind hier natürlich in
einem fließenden bereich von
meinungsfreiheit von internationalen
rechten interpretationen von rechten die
überall anders sind das ist nicht ganz
trivial und damit können sich teils
falsche und manipulative behauptungen
zum thema corona im netz weiter
verbreiten und innerhalb kürzester zeit
massen erreichen
was das für folgen haben kann erfahren
wir in göttingen von martin finanzen der
journalist betreibt der social media
watch blog und beobachtet seit jahren
die sozialen netzwerke und ihre teils
gefährliche sogwirkung
die gefahr bei den sozialen medien
besteht darin dass die angebote
natürlich aufgrund dessen dass er ein
interesse haben die leute so lange wie
möglich auf dieser plattform zu halten
das klingt erstmal ganz prima weil wenn
ich mich für rennradfahren interessiere
warum sollte mir facebook warum sollte
mich youtube sozusagen nicht eben noch
mehr inhalte zum thema rennradfahren
anbieten sie machen aber folgendes sie
werden sozusagen in der auswahl der
inhalte immer extrem aber es geht eben
darum wirklich nutzer immer ein bisschen
was kasse riss immer was emotionaleres
immer was ein deftiges so zu servieren
besonders über verschlüsselte
plattformen wie telegramm verbreiten
sich derzeit verschwörungs ideologische
inhalte allein dem kanal der ehemaligen
tagesschau moderatorin eva herman folgen
etwa 130 tausend follower hermann
verbreitet inhalte zur neuen weltordnung
einen bevölkerungsaustausch glaubt
journalisten seien gekauft
diese follower die bekommt man nicht mal
eben so geschenkt aufgrund irgendeiner
keiner pseudo prominenz sondern dass es
tatsächlich harte arbeit und die eva
herman die poster zum beispiel am tag um
die 100 nachrichten dort in ihrem
telegramm channel das sind nicht alles
selbst geschriebene nachrichten sondern
sie verbreitet ganz viele meldungen eben
von websites die aus dem einschlägigen
milieu stammen nach nur wenigen klicks
stoßen wie auf facebook gruppen wie
gemeinsam gegen die neue weltordnung
oder widerstand 2020
die menschheit sollte jetzt unbedingt
mal etwas tun womit die elite nicht
rechnet und zusammenhalten dann
beschwört diesen widerstand man
beschwört eben diese idee wir gegen die
da oben an sowas findet natürlich viel
anklagen zu gruppen weil es ist
natürlich etwas womit sich der
handwerker genauso identifizieren kann
wir vielleicht ein echter patriot der
schon seit zehn jahren vom untergang der
demokratie träumt und
so reift im netz ein widerstands gedanke
der laut auf die straße getragen wird
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unterschiedliche protestmails gemeinsam
gegen einen vermeintlichen feind
[Applaus]
was wir erleben ist dass solche
situationen ganz oft vom rechten lagern
sozusagen eine kapert wird und dann eben
dinge skandiert werden wo dann der ganz
normale familien würde sozial auf einmal
mit ist an dir zum beispiel wir sind das
volk oder widerstand und sich vielleicht
dann in so einer situation eben auch
dazu ermutigt sieht dort eben
entsprechend sich zu wort zu melden aber
viele womöglich gar nicht so ganz genau
weiß er während seiner seite marschiert
und was vielleicht die idee und die
intention eben das hier ist mit dem man
da jetzt auf einmal zusammen brüllt
verschwörungs erzählungen sind kein
neues phänomen einer bundesweiten studie
zufolge glaubt knapp die hälfte aller
bürger geheime organisationen hätten
großen einfluss auf politische
entscheidungen
von der psychologin pia lamberti wollen
wir uns erklären lassen was den reiz an
verschwörungstheorien ausmacht menschen
haben ganz starkes bedürfnis danach in
kontrolle zu sein und der glaube an
verschwörungen ist eben eine dieser
kompensations strategien bei dem man auf
einmal einen mächtigen akteur hat auf
dem man alles projizieren kann der
verschwörer es greifbar des virus
unsichtbar und dementsprechend ist es
handle bagger man hat einen fein gegen
die man angehen kann und das ist dann
eine art der bewältigungsstrategie
den typischen verschwörungstheoretiker
gb s p definition aber nicht
insgesamt ist es so dass man es vor
allem findet bei menschen die sich
politisch rechts verorten es ist aber
nicht so dass es nur auf menschen aus
diesem spektrum beschränkt ist und das
ist ja auch einer der gefahren das
verschwörungs erzählung von jeher das
potenzial hat menschen aus
unterschiedlichsten bereichen einander
zu verbinden im gemeinsamen feind
anhänger von verschwörungstheorien
nahezu allen gesellschaftsschichten
so sieht das auch das
bundesinnenministerium auf nachfrage
heißt es in der tat ist es eine
strategie insbesondere des
rechtsextremistischen spektrums das aus
diversen auch bürgerlichen milieus
gespeiste demonstrationsgeschehen im
zusammenhang mit corona für seine zwecke
nutzen zu wollen
allerdings seien auf den demonstrationen
auch die linksextremisten zu betrachten
heißt es weiter
derlei wechselwirkungen zwischen den
beiden antagonistischen extremismen
geben durchaus anlass zur sorge
bei der kundgebung von attila hildmann
kippt die stimmung langsam
die demonstranten und die polizei im
spannungsfeld zwischen
versammlungsfreiheit und corona
beschränkungen
es herrscht chaos auf der straße und
auch in manchen köpfen begleitet von
hass und radikalen feindbildern der
judenstern darauf das wort ungeimpft auf
dem t-shirt dieses demonstranten
kroner demo in halle in sachsen anhalt
wortführer der neonazis wenn liebig
vorbestraft unter anderem wegen
körperverletzung im netz vertreibt
liebig fragwürdige t shirts mit motiven
wie juden sternen und anne frank
das mädchen das hat er erfahrung im
eingeschlossen seien die hat ein halbes
jahr 50 betrag werden im hinterhaus in
amsterdam wohnen leben müssen weil sie
ihr politisch verfolgt wurde der code
ist egal anne frank musste sich vor den
nazis verstecken starb im
konzentrationslager
liebigs auftritte sind in erster linie
fürs netz ein anhänger nimmt die rede
auf
die rechten versuchen derzeit teile der
bevölkerung zu verunsichern
igor matwejew ist jude und lebt in halle
für ihn ist es kaum erträglich wie
liebig und seine anhänger opfer des
holocausts für ihre zwecke benutzen ist
eindeutige provokation auf kosten
weniger menschen auf kosten der opfer
des holocaust
es ist widerlich
unter liebigs demo teilnehmern entdecken
wir auch einen afd funktionär sven ebert
ist kreisrat im saalekreis wir sprechen
ihn auf die jugend sterne an
ok den zu benutzen zu sagen damit wurden
schon mal leute stigmatisiert und ja
zeigen darf das darf nie wieder
passieren
prima
seit jahren warnt der verfassungsschutz
vor liebigs rechtsextremen aktivitäten
für den afg kreisrat offensichtlich kein
thema richtig
krieg kein freund von mir
superreiche
wir versuchen mit sven liebig ins
gespräch zu kommen
sprechen nicht mit
ich spreche nicht mit der lügen brach
das ist ein prinzip von mir nein ich
spreche
das gespräch ist beendet
die anhänger des rechtsextremisten
bedrängen uns stören die dreharbeiten
liebig heizt die stimmung an wir
brauchen polizeischutz
letztlich eskortieren uns beamte bis zu
unserem auto
später schickt uns liebig über seinen
youtube kanal eine botschaft hinterher
die wende wird kommen und irgendwann
werdet ihr gz mauren nach ehrlichen
arbeit nachgehen müssen vielleicht das
erste mal in eurem leben
und so haben wir opfer sind wir hatten
wir natürlich uns auch als opfer
darstellen
torsten hahnel analysiert strukturen der
rechtsextremisten und kennt liebig und
seine aktivitäten schon lange versucht
natürlich seine antisemitischen altes
mit ihren teil zu bedienen und
gleichzeitig weiß er damit natürlich
eine maximale provokation erzielen kann
dass wir lokalpolitiker der afd auf
einer rechtsextremen demo von liebig
angetroffen haben sei kein zufall wie
ich möchte natürlich anschlussfähig sein
und er ist natürlich in das milieu der
afg anschlussfähig nicht umsonst macht
er ganz massiv werbung für die afg
heute tagt der stadtrat in halle wir
wollen rene schnabel treffen einen
kommunalpolitiker der afd hier bei einem
rechtsextremen aufmarsch 2009 10 in
berlin an dem auch liebig teilnahm wir
wollen mehr über seine verbindung zu dem
neonazi herausfinden
hallo ich wollte sie mal ganz kurz
fragen zu hören liebe ich
schalte ich ab und zu auf mord aber
unabhängig davon gebe ich in den
kommentaren schön dort und dass er mit
dem mit dem judenstern humboldt stört
sich das vielleicht ganz ungünstig
gewählt muss ich sagen
aber wenn man das hört also wie gesagt
ich bilde mir dazu keine meinung ich
wünsche mir schön an
dazu hatte sie jetzt gerade vor drehen
ich halte mich unheimlich gern auf dem
markt auf das richtige und mais kaffee
aber nicht bei den demonstrationen und
wenn dann gucke ich mir angucke noch
gerne die danach an oder am samstag
komplett drei stück halten auch gerne
alle angeguckt aber
doch auch diese aufnahmen zeigen ein
anderes bild hier 2009/10 rené schnabel
neben liebig
in berlin treffen wir erneut auf neonazi
liebig diesmal vor gericht er muss sich
wegen einer hetzkampagne verantworten
die ihr verbreitet hat
wir sind auch hier nicht willkommen
mein lieber
das ist ja schon kostenlos riesenbau
damit wie der handgreiflichkeiten
während liebe ich das geschehen live ins
netz stellt
auch sein auftritt vor den richtern eine
provokation ein rotes dreieck auf
gestreiftem hemd erinnert an die
kleidung der kz-häftlinge
die karikatur darf er nun nicht mehr
verbreiten das hindert liebe ich aber
nicht daran weiter stimmung zu machen
in düsseldorf treffen wir herbert reul
den innenminister von nordrhein
westfalen
sieht in verschwörungs mythen und dem
ideologischen missbrauch eine wachsende
gefahr für die demokratie wie schätzen
sie die situation ein dass diese szene
auch zunehmend von extremisten
unterwandert werden linksextreme
rechtsextrem 80 aller physischen bereich
nutzen das für ihre zwecke ist doch
vollkommen klar einfacher geht's ja
nicht den zweck den ich erreichen will
dafür bemüht sich menschen die so
blauäugig mit zu folgen
der minister sieht akuten
handlungsbedarf
verschwörungstheoretiker seien von den
behörden zu lange unterschätzt worden
also wir haben zum beispiel um in diesem
rechtsextremistischen bereich der
verschwörer weiterzukommen der
verfassungsschutz jetzt mit technologie
ausgestattet mit neuer die berge die
mengen die da im netz stattfindet kann
er kenne sich anguckt und deswegen
braucht man instrumente wie man sortiert
wie man das haus filtert wie man auch
wenn sich dann gruppenbild mehr wird es
kribbelig wenn man merkt dass da nicht
nur einer was macht sondern dass mehrere
sich auch noch verbinden weil sie den
großen umsturz organisieren wird ja dann
ist brenzlig und wenn man das verpasst
denn ist man draußen vor als
sicherheitsbehörde das hat der staat in
falsch gemacht dass sich die bürger
sofern ihm abwenden ich glaube schon
dass wir einiges falsch gemacht habe
wäre es nicht passiert wir haben zu
wenig erklärt wir haben am anfang in
bestimmten situationen auch falsch
reagiert weil wir nur gesagt haben die
sind alle idiotisch oder so und wir
haben erwartungen geschürt als könnte
politik alle probleme lösen also dieser
politiker der so simsalabim die welt
wieder in ordnung bringt wir sind sie
superhelden das macht ja spaß aber es
ist lebensgefährlich weil das kann keine
einlösen
das wird unsere nächste begegnung in
münchen bestätigen wir treffen max der
eigentlich anders heißt aber unerkannt
bleiben möchte weil er weiß dass seine
ansichten polarisieren der 36 jährige
erinnert sich noch genau an den moment
als er 2015 zum ersten mal mit so
genannten alternativen fakten in
berührung kam eine banane recherche zu e
zigaretten ließ ihn erwachen wie er
selbst sagt seitdem stellt er quasi
alles in frage
ich würde nicht sagen dass ich ein
verschwörungstheoretiker bin ich bin
jemand der sich für die wahrheit
interessiert
max ist in eine art parallelwelt
abgeglitten in den vergangenen jahren
wurden seine ansichten immer radikaler
ich wusste schon im voraus dass etwas
passieren wird das ein ereignis
passieren wird
es war nicht die frage ob sondern es war
nur die frage wann und jetzt jetzt
sind wir hier
also ich denke dieses virus ist auf
keinen fall zu fall
david rockefeller in seinen memoiren
geschrieben und gesagt alles was wir
brauchen ist eine richtig große krise
und die menschen werden die neue
weltordnung akzeptieren
max hat sich seine eigene version von
wahrheit geschaffen und gleichzeitig mit
dem system der demokratie
abgeschlossen das erfährst du dich von
bestimmten inhalten kriegst du mit was
rechts und linksextremisten posten
skandieren
also ganz ehrlich
ich finde diese unterteilung in rechts
links oben unten jung alt erwacht nicht
erwacht
verschwörungstheoretiker nicht
verschwörungstheoretiker das sind das
sind alles instrumente um leute zu
spalten wir sind alles menschen wir sind
eine menschheitsfamilie
und wir sollten alle zusammenhalten
ich hab keine rechtsextremisten gesehen
auf der demo
und wenn
also ich kann nicht pauschal sagen
distanziert du dich von den
rechtsextremisten
[Musik]
ihre geschichte begann bei den zeugen
jehovas
ich weiß durchaus wie es sowohl das
opfer zu sein als auch der täter als
auch die angehörige heute ist julia
silberberger nicht mehr bei den zeugen
jehovas sie arbeitet für die
organisation goldener armut kämpft gegen
verschwörungs erzählungen die korona
krise bietet den optimalen nährboden für
verschwörungstheorien
und die menschen haben angst angst dass
die triebfeder der verschwörungstheorien
menschen fühlen sich als ob sie die
kontrolle verloren hätten über ihr leben
und ich kann das verstehen der
mundschutz ist zu einem synonym dafür
geworden was die menschen durch die
korona krise alles ertragen müssen
sie berät vor allem angehörige von
verschwörungstheoretikern die nachfrage
danach sie wächst seit corona
ich weiß wie schmerzhaft es ist ich
kenne die emotionalen notlagen in deren
sich die personen befinden die sich
solchen theorien zu wenden und ich weiß
allerdings auch dass es sackgassen sind
denn im longrun ist das eine sache die
auf angst basiert und die den menschen
kaputt macht denn wenn du jeden tag mit
dem weltkrieg oder am weltuntergang oder
der zerstörung vor augen lebst kannst du
dauerhaft kein glücklicher mensch sein
es macht dich kaputt ist vermutlich sie
empfiehlt daher anhänger nicht
auszuschließen sondern ihre sorgen ernst
zu nehmen
wenn wir diese leute aus unserer mitte
ausstoßen einen rand der gesellschaft
drängt dann treiben wir sie in die arme
derer die sie schon sehnsüchtig erwarten
und das sind in der regel die
extremistischen gruppen das sind die
radikalen rechten gruppen müssen die
verschwörungs ideologischen gruppen weil
die werden sagen seht ihr ich habe es
euch doch gesagt komm zu uns wir heißen
euch willkommen und genau das ist das
was wir natürlich nicht erreichen wollen
und so zeigen zeiten wie diese dass
unser demokratisches system risse
bekommen hat denn auch wenn es sich um
eine minderheit handelt die im netz und
auf der straße protestiert ist sie laut
und kommt aus allen
gesellschaftsschichten
auch jetzt wochen nach dem show down
rufen aktivisten weiter zu
demonstrationen auf die korona krise hat
verschwörungstheorien in die
öffentlichkeit gebracht eine gefahr für
die demokratie
eine herausforderung für die
gesellschaft
[Musik]